كبار
امهم
كلهم
سعاده سعاده ملكه
ادمان المخدرات في تونس ظهيره اصبحت
مستشريه يدفع ضريبتها المجتمع باكمله
وارتبطت بعده جرائم شنيعه وفضيعه لكن يبقى
اخطرها تلك المرتبطه بعده عمليه ارهابيه
كله اعمل يعمل
في تونس اول مره سنه 2015 في العمليه
الارهابيين
سيف الدين
[موسيقى]
فكار والى نقاوه نلقاه بعض ثوم مدرسه
بيليتين بتاع مخدرات في همم لوكارت
[موسيقى]
اكثر من 300 نوعا من المخدرات في اسواق
تونس حولت 4 ملايين مواطن وما يقارب نصف
التلاميذ الى مستهلكين معطيات وصور
بدلالات مرعبه ولا حلول تلوح في الافق
ونشوف بالضبط
[موسيقى]
فلوس
الكثافه السكانيه في تونس من مستهلكي
المخدرات وخاصه القنب الهندي
يستهلك المخدرات بجميع انواعه
لاحد هنا بمنئه عن هذا المد احباط مجتمعا
انتظر انجازات الثوره فطورت في مستنقع
المخدرات ولم تنفع اصوار ومدارسه في تحسين
اطفالها من قطر الممنوعات سونامي يجتاح
شوارع تونس وازقتها ونرم خامده تحت رمادي
الصمت
[موسيقى]